hey what if your razor was designed by
the same aerospace machinist responsible
for making parts for the international
space station
the mars rover and low earth satellite
programs
yeah we're still talking razors here
people
henson shaving is doing just that now
they're different from your typical mass
market razor company henson shaving is
bringing the same precision to your
razor that they've been bringing to
space for the last 20 years i wonder
does that make them space razors all
right if you're like me over the years
you've been cut or knit or bloodied or
all of those things by dull blades or
bad products and you're probably not
entirely sure why well it turns out that
tiny little vibrations of the blade
are the culprit itself with
manufacturing tolerances of less than
half of a thousandth of an inch the team
at henson support the blade with
incredible precision which ultimately
limits the irritation that you get while
you're shaving and even better the
henson razor is plastic free it's made
to last for decades and the blades
themselves are recyclable a sustainable
approach that i can fully get behind and
you know if i can get behind this dark
talk can too so what are you waiting for
head to
hansonshaving.com and use code star talk
at checkout to pick up your razor and
get 100 blades for free that's
hensonshaving.com h-e-n-s-o-n
shaving dot com with code star talk 100
blades for free what are you waiting for
thank me later happy shaving
[Music]
chuck
yes have you heard of the five points of
lagrange
i gotta tell you
sounds like a michelin star restaurant
welcome to the five points
we will serve you the best of all yes
the gastro fantasy of your life
well lagrange himself
was a mathematician and he did happen to
be french yes as you okay surmised uh so
[Music]
uh it turns out
after we understood what gravity is and
how it worked
uh primarily through the equations of
isaac newton yes right so here we are if
you have two objects just sitting there
they fall towards each other
but you can actually put one object in
orbit around the other okay
and then it then it's still
they're still falling towards each other
but it's also moving sideways as it does
it so it never actually hits it
okay that's the that's a little hard for
some people to capture and embrace
because you got to think about it in 3d
you can't think about it exactly you
can't think about it as just something
as a line as a line going towards one
another right correct correct the moon
is falling towards the earth but it
happens to be going sideways really fast
right and you combine those two facts it
takes it into orbit so there you have it
all right
so let's think up a few things let's say
uh you want to travel from earth to the
moon like in a straight line
okay
does it make sense that there will be a
point
where earth's force of gravity on you
will exactly equal the moon's force of
gravity on you
oh oh yeah i mean that they both have
gravity it's kind of a
it's an outsized tug of war i like the
analogy right so we can stand on earth
and we're not just pulled into the moon
you can stand on the moon you're not
pulled into earth there's got to be some
point where it's exactly equal
okay yeah yeah that makes sense
that point is the first point of
lagrange
ah
exactly that is what we like to call the
amuse bush
[Music]
the first course
[Laughter]
so silly
okay for those who have nev who've only
ever eaten at wendy's tell everyone what
the amuse bush is so you know sometimes
before
if you're at a you know an upscale
restaurant before everything starts they
will come over and they will give you
just a small taste normally
on a tiny little something and you know
it looks like it's a complimentary
offering but it's not it's just it's not
it's it's not a line item on your bill
but you paid for it but you paid for it
you know so it's yeah
okay so now
let's keep going
so that's a balance point number one
that's so it turns out that point is
much closer to the moon as you might
imagine okay it would have to be because
earth's gravity is stronger than that
much stronger you got it closer to the
moon to for that to balance out all
right right
but the earth moon system
rotates okay
so
let's think about this if it's rotating
there's also sort of a centrifugal force
in the system
that wants things to fly away right if
you happen to be there
okay
so in this rotating system
you okay
on the other side of the moon
there is a point
where the earth moon rotating system is
flinging that in such a way
that its urge to fall towards the earth
and the moon is balanced
by the centrifugal force to have it fly
away oh
that's it so there's another lagrangian
point l2
right on the other side the other side
okay and in order for that to work you
have to give it
an orbit around the earth that stays
behind the moon
as it goes around
okay right so okay i got you it's like
the inner circle that's the
point on the earth and the moon right
then there's an outer circle outer one
right and there's a there's a spot where
you can find that spot calculate where
that spot is and if you have it
revolve around the system
in the same way the moon is you will
feel the centrifugal force push you away
and the gravitational force pull you in
and you're balanced so let me ask you
this then yeah um okay i'm just trying
to figure this out
so on that outer point is it taking into
account the gravity of the earth too yes
it is both the earth and the moon are
trying to pull it in the same same
direction yeah so
not only is that point l2 on the other
side of the moon you might guess
there's a counterpart to that point on
the other side of the earth oh right why
not of course of course okay so now
we've got l1 between earth and the moon
l2 beyond the moon l3 beyond the earth
gotcha
okay
these are lagrange points where all the
forces balance
okay
magnifique
yes the alignment of the points in front
and back of the moon the earth and in
between
it makes for what how shall we say
how
so
so now
there are two more points we covered
three out of five there are two more
points one is ahead of the moon in its
orbit okay and one trails the moon in
its orbit
okay ahead of and behind and if you map
this out that forms equilateral
triangles
between earth moon and those points
pointing forward an earth moon and that
other point
in the trailing spot
it turns out those two lagrange points
are special
because they are stable
oh
they're stable
think this through look at l1
if that's if the point between earth and
moon is where they balance
suppose i just give you a little nudge
in one direction or the other what
happens well then you're you're moving
out of there you're moving out of there
you're moving out of there you were
balanced at the top of a gravitational
hill right
same is true for l2 and l3 right
whereas l
four and l5
if you put something there and nudge it
it stays
okay
it stays
that's like the difference between
balancing a marble at the top of a hill
and
balancing a marble at the bottom between
two hills right the top of the hill that
a gust of air will send it over the side
a gust of air when it's at the bottom
between two hills it'll move but it'll
go right back right back okay
the l5 society you may have heard of it
from decades ago is a is a is a group of
people who wanted to colonize space they
were going to build a space habitat at
l5
ah very very illuminati of them yes it
was
let's escape leave earth behind
while they blow during the cold war too
so
so that's the difference among these
these places so the l5 society they've
got a place they can
haul all manner of hardware and it'll
just stay there and they just grab it
and assemble it and you get your habitat
module it's like a natural space station
yes well in terms of location yes it
stands a location yeah yes yes okay so
now
any pair of objects has these have these
lagrangian points
any pair okay
the earth and the sun have lagrangian
points
okay
so there's a lagrangian point between
earth and the sun and one beyond the
earth and one beyond the sun just like
there was with the earth and the moon
the earth and the moon right okay the
one beyond the earth
is a million miles from earth and that's
where we put the james webb space
telescope because at that location
earth permanently eclipses the sun
awesome preventing the
sunlight from streaming onto these very
sensitive detectors that's trying to
find very dim very cool objects in the
outer universe that is brilliant
it's kind of like
the equivalent of when you don't have
your sun visor down in your car and you
just take your hand and you you
basically block out the sun so that you
can see
beyond what's the front of your car it's
like or world war ii pilots and i
learned this from watching the tv show
so i don't know if it's real or not okay
i hate quoting tv shows because you
never know if they're lying to you
you're good half the time maybe okay
yeah but they said um when the guys were
in the um
the fighter uh
planes they're not the prop planes like
spitfires
and they just have the all glass
you know cockpit
that when the sun would come there of
course they don't have a visor it's all
glass that one of the things you would
do is just take your thumb and place it
in a point where your thumb is blotting
out the sun so that you can see the
surroundings around you that's exactly
what's going on with the james webb
space telescope a million miles from
earth in the opposite direction of the
sun at the earth sun l2 point
that's
awesome
that is great it's so it's totally good
that's it that's why it's called rocket
science okay
as a matter of fact it is rocket science
so you want some more lagrangian points
yep okay there's a satellite
at the
earth sun l1 lagrangian point
that is always between earth and the sun
and it's always just looking at earth
it's just staring at earth okay that's
the discover satellite that has
continuous monitoring
of one side of the earth as earth
rotates
and it's actually pointed and focused on
just one house
of the guy who created it
and is waiting to see what his wife is
doing
i went through all this i know you're
doing something girl
i got this billion dollar satellite for
the proof all right so the thing to know
here is
for the lagrangian points that are not
stable
that's l1 l2 and l3
it doesn't take much energy to keep it
there the station keeping okay
so the james webb space telescope at the
earth sun l2
has fuel that as it begins to slowly
drift away they send it back
okay so i i didn't want to misrepresent
the the stability of that point uh you
think of a marble on a very narrow
sloped hill it's a very wide hill
right okay it's a very wide hill so
it'll start
rolling off the hill you just sort of
push it back a little with hardly any
energy because you it's not a steep hill
so you just push it a little bit you get
it back in place so you can still use
these
unstable lagrangian points but you need
station keeping energy to do so
wow it's kind of like uh when you have a
little child
that you're walking with
every once in a while that kid want to
run ahead you like hey hey
get back here
no because you don't want it to run into
the street you know no it's true it's
true okay one last thing okay you ready
the stable lagrangian points in the sun
jupiter system okay
everybody any two things orbiting each
other has five lagrangian points so the
sun jupiter you go ahead of jupiter and
behind jupiter there are pockets
in the space of the solar system that
have trapped asteroids
they're leading asteroids and trailing
asteroids asteroids check in but they
don't check out check out it's exactly
right because it's a stable place
it's at the bottom of a gravitational
well
and the the trailing asteroids are
called the trojan asteroids right and
the leading asteroids are called the
greek asteroids and so a little bit of
you know a little bit of history there
they should have called them the
spartans
this is lagrange
and there are 300 of them
so
lagrangian points matter in the solar
system when we're looking at where
things collect where things drift what
they drift out of and we are exploiting
those for our own
gain where we gonna put telescopes and
possibly the future of
habitats yeah orbiting habitats that we
put people where all the all the
illuminati go as you suspect
[Laughter]
all right chuck that's all the time we
got that was that was that push
yeah that's right
that was suckling blue thank god it was
absolutely a deadly show
i'm trying to see what wine we would
have had with that a little bit bald
though
i don't know
the finest boat door in
in all of
bordeaux
all right let's get off of this before
we get hate mail from the french out
there absolutely
all right this has been another
explainer for star talk all about
lagrange
until next time keep looking up
[Music]